Endometriosis is
a condition where
tissue, similar to the
lining in your uterus,
grows in other
areas of your body.
If you are a woman,
your reproductive system
includes the vagina, uterus,
fallopian tubes, and ovaries.
During a normal
menstrual cycle, you're
ovaries make chemicals
called hormones, which
signal the lining of
your uterus to thicken.
The lining, called
the endometrium,
builds up to prepare to
receive a fertilized egg.
If the egg isn't
fertilized, the uterus
sheds the lining
through your vagina.
This monthly bleeding is
called your menstrual period.
If you have endometriosis,
the lining type tissue
grows outside your uterus for
reasons that aren't clear.
The misplaced tissue
response to the hormones
just like it would if it
were inside your uterus.
The tissue continues
to thicken, then
sheds, and bleeds with
every menstrual cycle.
However, the blood
and tissue that
are shed outside the uterus
have no way to leave your body.
The trapped endometrial flow can
irritate the surrounding area
causing inflammation and pain.
Bands of scar tissue,
called adhesions,
may form, sticking
one organ to another
or causing your
fallopian tubes to close.
This can affect your
fertility, which
is the ability to
become pregnant.
Endometriosis can form
endometriomas, also known
as chocolate cysts.
These cysts are fluid
filled sacs on your ovaries
that can affect fertility.
Endometriosis may also
result in abnormal bleeding.
The most common sites
for endometriosis
are the ovaries,
fallopian tubes,
the outside of your uterus,
the supporting structures
around your uterus, and
the lining of your pelvis,
called the peritoneum.
Other sites include
your bladder, rectum,
and intestines.
If you have endometriosis,
you may have one or more
of these symptoms,
chronic usually worsening
central pelvic pain, pain before
or during your period, pain
during sex felt deep
within your pelvis,
painful urination
during your period,
painful bowel movements
abnormal bleeding, diarrhea,
constipation, or nausea,
and difficulty getting
pregnant called infertility.
Your doctor may recommend
treatment options
from the following categories,
pain management medications,
such as aspirin,
acetaminophen, or non-steroidal
anti-inflammatory drugs,
also known as nsaids,
provide relief from pain.
Hormone therapy, such
as birth control pills,
can prevent monthly endometrial
buildup and bleeding.
You may need a
surgical procedure
to treat the tissue
causing pain or bleeding.
Examples of such procedures
include, removal or destruction
of endometrial issue, removal
of adhesions and scar tissue,
removal or drainage of
cysts, removal or destruction
of nerve fibers that transmit
pain, removal of your uterus,
called a hysterectomy, or
removal of your ovaries,
called an oophorectomy.